حيث تواصل المعارضه ترتيب اوراقها
لمواجهتي المنافس الاقوى في الانتخابات
الرئاسيه المقبله وهو الرئيس الحالي رجب
طيب اردوغان صاحب الفتره الطويله في حكم
هذه البلاد فضلا عن المنافسه السياسيه فان
المواجهه بين المعارضه التركيه واردوغان
اخذت طابعا دستوريا وقانونيا ايضا وذلك من
خلال التشكيك في قانونيه ترشحه لولايه
الثالثه المعارضه التركيه تقول ان ترشح
اردوغان يعد انتهاكا للدستور مشدده على
انه غير مؤهل قانونيا لانه سوف بالفعل
المدد الرئاسيه المسموح بها وهما ولايتان
لا يمكن ان يترشح لولايه الثالثه فهل
اردوغان غير مؤهل للترشح للانتخابات
الرئاسيه القادمه في تركيا هذا هو السؤال
الدخان يستند في موقفه على قاعده دستوريه
تسمح للرئيس بالترشح لاكثر من ولايتين في
حال تم اجراء انتخابات مبكرا وهو الحال
بالنسبه للانتخابات القادمه والتي بات من
المرتقب اجرائها في الرابعه عشر من ما
يؤلمبل غير ان معارضي ترشح اردوغان
يعتبرون ان هذه القاعده الدستوريه لاغيه
لان اجراء انتخابات مبكرا لم يتم بدعوه من
البرلمان بل من الرئيس التركي الذي استخدم
صلاحياته الدستوريه على الصعيد السياسي
تواصل المعارضه ترتيب اوراقها لاقناع
الناخبين تحالف المعارضه واصل تقديم
التعهدات في تحقيق نقل سياسيه واعتماد
توزيع جديد للسلطات في البلاد من اهم
الوعود التي اطلقها التحالف وارساء نظام
يخالف النظام الحالي الذي وضعه الرئيس
اردوغان وذلك بارساء نظام برلمانيا مع
رئيس بدور فخري لمنتخبا لولايه واحده تمتد
على سبع سنوات
التي اتفقنا اذا نجران
سياسه المشتركه التي تم اعدادها في مطابخ
الاحزاب السياسيه السته التي تشكل تحالف
الامه المعروفه ايضا باسم مليتا والتي
تتضمن اهدافا ملموسه واصلاحات وسياسات
ومشاريعه من شانها اخراج بلدنا من الازمه
من اجل نظام برلماني متحرر وديمقراطي
وعادل يضمن الفصل بين السلطات بدلا من هذا
النظام الغريب الذي لا يعترف باي قواعد